j'aime beaucoup la cueillette et on est
un petit peu privé l'a pas pouvoir aller
cueillir soi-même mais bon voilà je
trouve que c'est
c'est une très belle idée d'avoir mis ça
en place plus de cueillette dans les
champs afin d'éviter tout contact entre
les clients mais pour autant il reste
donc possible de s'approvisionner en
fruits et légumes auprès des fermes de
gally ce qu'on a proposé c'est la
première fois qu'on le fait c'est de
réaliser des des cagettes de légumes
frais puisqu'ils ont été cueillis ce
matin ils ont été mis dans les cages est
là cette fin de matinée on l'est on les
distribue le jeudi après-midi pour
l'unss entre 15h et 17h un vrai attrait
parce que beaucoup de gens ont du mal à
trouver des légumes frais et recherche
des légumes en circuit court donc c'est
ce qu'on pratique nous depuis plus de 30
ans à la cueillette de gally épinards
blade salade et même tulipes pour passer
les commandes il faut se rendre sur le
site de l'établissement et payer en
ligne
le point de contact est très très rapide
on a le nom la liste des gens qui ont
réglé leurs cagettes
ils viennent sur un créneau de deux
trois heures ils donnent leur nom on
vérifie oreilles ils partent avec
l'horreur malgré tout la diminution de
l'activité est notable et autres
difficultés que rencontre cette
entreprise agricole
la poursuite également des plantations
pour les autres saisons courgettes
aubergines ou encore tomates pour
s'assurer de la bonne continuité du
travail certains postes ont ainsi été
modifié on a une entreprise qui est
assez diversifié donc il ya des branches
de l'entreprise qui sont très touchées
est d'ailleurs une partie de ses
salariés qui n'avaient plus de travail
du fait de la conjoncture sont embauchés
et viennent travailler en entraide sur
d'autres activités
l'activité agricole ne peut pas
s'arrêter six mois si on arrête tout
ça va être difficile de manger